hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be taking
another deep dive into the latest
revelations about
dobby's true identity and this includes
the exact moment when the boy we knew as
toyah todoroki died
and the villain we now know as dabi was
born
some really intense and really emotional
reveals were just made
so let's get into it if you enjoy our
boku no hero videos and you want to see
more
leave a like and comment it really does
help
and if you're new to animal pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications i often get people
telling me that they're surprised that
they constantly miss
my videos that's because on youtube it's
no longer enough to just subscribe
you have to subscribe click the bell and
then select the option that says all
it's annoying but it's how it works
finally this video will contain boku no
hero manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
in the latest installment of the boku no
hero story we finally see the rest of
dobby's tragic backstory if you haven't
seen my video breaking down the previous
chapter
and the first half of that backstory
definitely check it out
i will link it in the description and
also in the pinned comment
i also want to say that this new chapter
did not answer
all of our questions it did answer a lot
of questions but there is still one big
mystery about dobby's life that is
yet to be revealed and i will talk about
that later on in the video
so after that incident in which a
jealous and enraged
toyah tried to hurt baby shoto endeavour
decided to ban shoto's other siblings
including toya from interacting with him
endeavour was determined to distance
both shoto
and himself from toyah because he didn't
want toya to keep trying to become a
hero
since endeavour is a full-time pro hero
and since shoto was being groomed
to become a pro hero endeavor decided
that they must both keep their distance
from toyah this obviously wasn't a great
solution
since toya wanted so desperately to be
accepted by his father
and this was achieving the exact
opposite in fact
rey was rightly upset with endeavour's
decision and she asked him
what kind of hero runs away from his own
son but
endeavour was stubborn and he continued
to push
toya away from him some five years after
the baby shoto
incident when toya was 13 and shoto was
5
we see that endeavour is still
continuing with that same approach
instead of allowing shoto to play with
his siblings endeavour is forcing him to
focus
exclusively on his training he is
effectively banning shoto from leading a
normal life with his siblings
which creates a great distance between
the other kids
and shoto and of course this only
increases toya's resentment
towards his little brother all toya ever
wanted to do in life was become a hero
and achieve his father's dream and now
shoto is getting
all of his dad's attention while toya
only gets ignored and rejected by his
own father toya's resentment is further
showcased when we see him complaining to
natsu about endeavour's decision to
ditch him and prevent him from becoming
a hero
natsu isn't really interested in toyah's
complaints and you can tell that toya
has been doing this a lot
so he tells him to just go complain to
fuyumi instead
this demonstrates that the other two
todoroki siblings didn't care nearly as
much about endeavour's coldness
as toyah did ironically before
desperately wanting to make his father
suffer toya desperately wanted to be
closer to his father
and he cared about him much more than
his other siblings did
even at this point in his life five
years after endeavour told him to give
up on being a hero
toya is still determined to train and
get stronger so that he can surpass
all might he still wants to be the one
to make his father's dream come true
and he continues to sneak out on his own
and train
up in the mountains rey can tell that
toya is obsessed with his father
and with gaining his father's approval
and she tries to explain that there are
so many other things in life that he
could be doing with his time
there is so much more to life than just
pleasing endeavor and becoming a hero
and toya needs to focus on himself and
finding out what he really wants to be
and what he really wants to do
independent of endeavour's desires
but toya just snaps at his mom saying
that she is also to blame for everything
that's been happening because she agreed
to a quirk marriage with endeavour
so if being strong and becoming a hero
isn't a big deal
then why did she decide to marry someone
for the sole purpose of creating
offspring with
strong quirks at this point toya seems
to have concluded that mastering his
quirk and becoming a hero
is his singular purpose in life and so
he continues to train until his flames
eventually change from red
to blue during his training toya also
realizes that the power of his flames is
directly connected to his emotions
and that will become important later
after his flames change color
toya regains his confidence and he
decides to show his new power
to his father he invites endeavor to
come to sekuto hill during the holiday
break because he wants to show his
father that his flames are now blue
and even more powerful than they were
before but instead of being supportive
endeavour is outraged when he learns
that toya has been secretly training
and that he has burns all over his body
again endeavour is concerned about
toyah's safety
and that's why he doesn't want toya to
keep training and hurting himself
so in his own strange way endeavour does
care about his son but he is pretty
terrible at showing that he actually
cares about him
for his part toya is also incredibly
stubborn
and he is determined to convince his
father to accept him no matter what
toya is desperate to show his father
that he can be the one to surpass
all might and that he wasn't a mistake
not only is toyah deeply hurt by his
father's abandonment and rejection but
he seems to believe that unless he can
achieve his father's dream of surpassing
all might then his entire existence
was a mistake that is such a terrible
mindset to have
but i can definitely see where toya got
this idea
if he was only born because of a quirk
marriage and if his father's main goal
for having children was so that one of
them could one day surpass
all might then toa feels that if he
can't do it
his life was a mistake his existence
has no purpose he was nothing but a
faulty prototype
and now shoto will become everything
that he could not
this is a pretty dark place for any
child to be in
in that formative age and i can't help
but feel bad for toya
at this point he would be much better
off if he wasn't so stubborn
but he is still just a kid and with a
distant and cold father-like endeavor
we can't really expect toyah to be an
exemplar of emotional intelligence
we then see a brief scene in which
little shoto defends his mom from an
enraged endeavor who screams at rey for
not preventing toyah from training
but rey simply can't do it on her own
she has three other children to take
care of
and since endeavour has pretty much
given up on spending any time with toyah
rey cannot keep watch over him like 24
7. and i mean rey is totally right here
imagine having four kids with someone
and he decides to pretty much abandon
three of them so that he can focus
all of his energy on training one of
them that is totally unfair
and ridiculous endeavour ultimately
decides not to go to sekhoto hill
at the scheduled time because he doesn't
want to encourage toyah to keep
doing this he doesn't want toya to keep
training and hurting his body
he believes that toya would be much
better off if he just gave up on being a
hero
and moved on with his life but it's not
that easy
just as endeavour has been obsessed with
surpassing all might for years
toya has become obsessed with becoming a
hero and achieving his father's dream
toya couldn't just let go of his dream
any more than endeavour
could let go of his own dream of
becoming the number one pro hero
while sitting alone up on secure hill
toya
begins to cry after being rejected by
his father
yet again he becomes intensely emotional
and because his quirk and his flames are
directly connected to his emotions
toya's entire body suddenly bursts into
flames just as i speculated in my
previous videos
in the moment of his alleged death toya
lost control
of his own flames and that is what led
to the big
fire the fire which scorched the entire
hill
and which was believed to have taken
toya's life
this is the exact moment when shoto's
brother toya dies
and eventually a new person will be born
in his place
a ruthless villain dobby but that is of
course
a symbolic death because we know that
toya didn't actually die
even though parts of him were apparently
found on the scene
including a fragment of his jawbone so
what happened to toya how did he survive
and what did he do for all of those
years between the big fire
and his rebirth as the villain dobby
that
is the last piece of the dobby puzzle
the
final mystery and this chapter does not
answer that question it leaves us
guessing as to what happened to toya
after the fire and i hope that we will
learn how exactly he went from being a
severely injured 13 year old kid
who was presumed dead to a cruel villain
named dabi
who emerges about a decade later did
someone find
toya nurse him back to health and set
him down the path of becoming a villain
i really do hope that this final
unanswered question will be addressed
sometime
soon because i'm very curious to find
out what happened to him right
after that big fire now after toyah was
presumed
dead endeavour was devastated he simply
didn't know what to do
and since he couldn't face the
consequences of his actions
he refused to let himself take a step
back instead of just giving up on his
obsession to surpass
all might he doubled down on the plan to
make shoto into the ultimate hero
and so his obsession continued as rey
points out
after toyah's disappearance endeavour
got even worse
and eventually she began to lose her
mental stability as well
i mean not only did she tragically lose
one son
but she was also losing her other son
shoto because of endeavour's obsession
back in the hospital room fuyumi and
natsu also expressed their regret for
not doing more to reach out to toya
before it was too late
rey says that even though endeavour's
obsession drove this whole thing
in the end the entire todoroki family
failed
toya and they must now all get together
to bring an
end to this nightmare rey also says that
shoto is the todoroki family's
true hero despite everything that he had
been through with both endeavor and rey
he has become a great hero he has
evolved as a person
and against all odds he brought the
entire family back together again
well except for toyah of course shoto
then approaches endeavor and holds out
his hand
he says to his father that once he's
done crying
he needs to get up and they all must go
to stop toya
together and that is how this intense
and emotional chapter ends wow
what an emotional rollercoaster both
endeavor
and shoto have evolved so much as
characters since the beginning of this
story
and now we are seeing rey and the other
todoroki siblings evolving as well
that moment with the family finally
coming together for a common purpose
with shoto holding his hand out to a
crying endeavor
absolutely brilliant and it's so sad to
see that after all this time
toya is still obsessed with his father
it's just that instead of being obsessed
with earning his father's acceptance he
is now obsessed with making his father
suffer toya aka dabi is the only
todoroki who hasn't evolved at all
from an emotional perspective if
anything he just continues to devolve
in the most tragic way possible so
what happens next is there a way to
actually get through to dobby
or is he already beyond saving if he is
beyond saving
is this looming confrontation between
dobby and the todoroki family going to
result in someone's death
also what do you guys think actually
happened to toya
after the fire did someone find him and
nurse him back to health
did that person also sent him down on
the path to becoming a villain
or was that someone else definitely let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments below
and let me know how you liked this
chapter if you enjoyed
this video and you want us to keep it
going with the boku no hero content
please leave that like to let me know
it only takes a second but it really
does help and if you're new to anime pro
or maybe you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar a big thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata the world
a quiet respect pate heffa liam thompson
algetal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life tinel baked
buddhist and
tungsten tarkis finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh steelers on
hell cruise anatoly kazotsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond rafaelin de ora alicia octor bonnie
parks hinokami and water the red-haired
raven joanne garcia jack watches anime
fat boy games ted no ted deadly saint
matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you